las vegas now jersey shore star vinnie g
is taking the stage again as the
celebrity host for the chippendales at
the rio i caught up with him as he
prepares to put on the bow tie
are you ready
[Applause]
third time's a charm that's what i'm
saying we're so excited to have you
joining the chippendales cast again like
we're saying you're you're a hot
commodity are you excited to kick it off
again this weekend
yeah i mean it's a pretty good feeling
you know that they keep asking me back
um we had like two sold out runs in a
row um so if it's not broke don't fix it
and um the more i do it the more
comfortable and confident i get up there
and i feel like the better it's gonna be
during the pandemic i actually worked a
lot because like the world still needed
reality television and um
we were like going to just like resorts
that were like coveted bubbles and we
were just like filming we did like three
seasons during cobit i feel so um jersey
shore family vacation is still going
we're still following and documenting
our lives as we grow and evolve and um
you know it still has like the highest
ratings of a reality show
on tv every thursday i mean people watch
it live which is kind of crazy we're
really excited about it you're among a
great group of guys over there and i
know you're just going to take it to the
next level so we can't wait to see it
and thank you so much for playing along
today yeah come out and see me because
um you know once the residencies end i'm
not there anymore i think
people think that like now i'm just
always there whenever they go they'll
like they'll like message me in like
december and be like i want the chip and
nails you weren't there so march 11th
april 10th come see me on the weekend
that's right you can check out vinnie g
alongside the chippendale guys with
nightly shows starting tonight through
april 10th you can get your tickets
online through ticketmaster and i'm
going to check out the show tonight so
i'll bring you guys some more fun
content on monday we'll be right back